>> Chris: FINALLY TONIGHT,
THIS WEEK’S NOTABLE
QUOTABLES.
>> WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT’S
MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
IT’S BOOMING.
>> WE ARE LOOKING LIVE AT
POINT TERMS WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN.
>> PRESIDENT AND CHIEF OF
STAFF HAVE HAD FULL
CONFIDENCE AND TRUST IN HIS
ABILITIES AND HIS
PERFORMANCE.
>> I TOLD THEM ALL OF THE
DETAILS OF MY MARRIAGE,
INCLUDING VERBAL AND
EMOTIONAL ABUSE.
>> I THINK A LOT OF US COULD
HAVE DONE BETTER.
>> COMEY IS GONE, MCCABE
LETTER THE FBI.
LISA PAGE BEEN DEMOTED.
>> ABSOLUTE.
[WHISPERING]
>> OMAROSA WAS FIRED THREE
TIMES ON THE APPRENTICE.
AND THIS IS THE FOURTH YOU
TIME WE LET HER GO.
>> WE ARE TRAVELING TO THE
OLYMPICS TO MAKE SURE THAT
NORTH KOREA DOESN’T PAPER
OVER THE TRUTH ABOUT THEIR
REGIME.
>> I WOULD DESCRIBE IT,
DANA, AS A COLLECTIVE EYE
ROLL FROM MILITARY LEADERS
WHO HAVE I SPOKEN TO.
MOST THOUGHT IT WAS A JOKE
AT FIRST.